moi j'ai la chance d'être encore là en
ce moment pour vous parler cet
adolescent est reconnaissant d'être
encore en vie il y a moins d'un an il a
fait l'objet d'un complot pour meurtre
de la part de quatre élèves de son école
secondaire à montréal après ça ça va
être une étape de me reconstruire avec
les gens autour donc comment est-ce que
je réintègre le cirque sociaux
commencent que je vais gérer mais mes
relations humaines ça va surtout est ce
qu'ils vont prendre du temps l'été
dernier quatre jeunes de 15 ans de son
école décide de comploter pour le tuer
inspiré par la tuerie de columbine en
1999 aux états unis le groupe planifiera
aussi de reproduire une tuerie de masse
en surprenant des élèves en classe le
plan du quatuor sera déjoué par le spvm
dès la rentrée scolaire la 5 septembre
reçoit un appel la police
a des raisons de croire qu'il ya des
menaces envers notre fils questionné par
les policiers l'une des quatre complices
est passé aux aveux mettant un terme à
l'exécution du plan dans des échanges
texte présenté en preuve tout était
prévu pour faire un massacre et si à
glacer le sang de voir tout ce qu la
minute par minute deux des quatre jeunes
accusés ont reçu des peines de 12 et 15
mois de probation aujourd'hui après
avoir plaidé coupable à des accusations
de menaces de mort et de complot de
voies de fait graves ils devront
également présenter des lettres d'
excuses à tous des élèves de l'école
visée on souhaite que les jeunes
prennent leurs responsabilités et il y
en a qu'on prenne ce qu'ils ont posé
comme geste l'impact de ces gestes là
notamment le feu sur les victimes dans
les circonstances il ya des profonds
regrets du côté de mes clients il ya une
remise en question qui a eu lieu le père
de l'adolescent pense aux parents de
duval des au texas qui n'ont pas eu la
chance que la police intervienne à temps
ils vivent parce que ça a échoué on est
content du processus mons transpose aux
parents là bas et avec avec une
situation qui est irréelle j'ai la télé
dans mon bureau pour qu'on travaille
aussi le à toutes les fois de sa vie en
face cette espèce de pression ici
orville choc les deux autres jeunes
accusés dans le complot seront cités à
procès en octobre prochain en attendant
la petite famille devrait faire preuve
de courage jusqu'à la fin des procédures
judiciaires ici pascal robidas radio
canada montréal